holmes ist eine influenza in die ihre
fans über acht jahre via youtube an
ihrem leben teilhaben dies im frühjahr
dieses jahres bekam sie die nachricht
dass sie an leukämie erkrankt war jetzt
sechs monate später die freundin an
einem bewegenden video verkündet dass
die junge frau den kampf gegen die
krankheit verloren hat
[Musik]
ich liebe euch alle wenn ihr das hört
werde ich euch vom himmel aus beobachten
meint nicht aber wenn die beiden volt
ist es auch okay lasst uns alle ganz
viel lachen ich werde euch vom himmel
aus zu prusten mit babbel team ich liebe
euch alle
[Musik]
ok
besser bekannt unter ihrem online namen
hajou sarah ist eine bekannte
australische youtube mit gut 300.000
verloren ihre themen food und südkorea
[Musik]
auch ihren freund und späteren verlobten
lernzeit in südkorea kennen lässt ihre
fans an ihre liebesgeschichte mit
täglichen pos teilhaben
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht wie ich es sagen soll
123 wir sind verlobt
regelmäßig verfolgen hunderttausende die
videos der in südkorea lebenden
australierin manche videos erreichen gar
millionenpublikum doch im mai dieses
jahres zeit sarah diese schockierende
nachricht mit ihren fans
[Musik]
wie im titel dieses videos lesen könnt
wurde bei mir leukämie diagnostiziert
ich kann es immer noch nicht glauben der
grund warum ich ein gut trage ist
ich bin jetzt so ich kann nur lachen
ehrlich gesagt ich habe schon so viel
gelacht wenn man nicht lacht weint man
nur noch mehr oder
[Musik]
sarah macht auch ihren kampf gegen die
tödliche krankheit öffentlich dabei
zeigt sie sich stets fröhlich und
lebensfroh naja
also wirklich ich war echt traurig und
hatte schwere zeiten aber eure
kommentare zu lesen hat mir sehr viel
energie gegeben viele fragen mich wie
sie leuten in meiner situation helfen
können und es ist ganz einfach spendet
blut
server lässt ihre fans am verlauf ihrer
erkrankung teilhaben und kämpft auf
ihrem kanal informiert sie und wirbt
auch für stammzellen spenden nicht nur
für sich selbst
[Musik]
viele user sind dankbar für ihre
offenheit am 31 juli schließlich geht's
er ein letztes mal live auf youtube
hallo wir feiern eine pyjama-party wir
haben jetzt auch eine avocado kissen er
massierten jetzt immer den kopf bevor
wir ins bett gehen ich mochte das früher
gar nicht aber es hilft mir sehr ich
schlafe dann viel schneller ein okay wir
müssen aufhören es ging so schnell
vorbei ich will gar nicht aufhören dass
leute doch nun hat er den kampf gegen
die bösartige krankheit verloren sarah
wurde nur 31 jahre alt
[Musik]